- All right, let's finish things up
with one last uplifting story, y'all.
This is What I'm Liking.
(jazz music)
(audience cheers)
So it's one of the biggest
cliches of the pandemic, right?
People make in sourdough.
I mean, I still can't make
it, but other people did it.
Like a lot of people.
65-year-old Arnie in the Bronx
hopped aboard that bread train
and it led to a wonderful
and unexpected journey,
as well as a new business.
So let's get Arnie on the line
who watches on NBC New York at two.
What's up, Arnie?
(audience cheers)
- Hey, Kelly.
Great to see you.
- [Kelly] Oh, it's good to see you too.
- Thank you for having me.
- Well, I have to start with that.
God, that looks so good
right in front of you.
So let's start with the bread.
Let's start there.
How did you, how did this happen?
- I'm a commercial photographer.
I shoot for businesses and
magazines and even weddings.
And when the pandemic came, I had no work.
And I needed something to
do to keep from going crazy.
And I've always loved
sourdough bread, eating it.
And, but I was always
intimidated on how to make it.
And because the first
thing you need is a starter
and this can take a couple
of weeks to actually develop.
And I, was just intimidated.
But then my daughter made
some and gave it to me
and I started making it.
And I gotta tell you,
it was terrible.
It, it was embarrassing
what I was getting.
(Kelly laughs)
But, I have a friend
who's a professional baker
and I was posting my disasters
and he kept on giving me tips
on how to make it better and better.
And some, about a month,
I started making breads
that I was really proud of.
And then I found, I love the
process of making the bread
almost as much as eating it.
And I really like eating sourdough bread.
So I'm making all these loaves
and I gotta figure out what
am I gonna do with them?
So at first,
I started bringing 'em to the
local pantry, food pantry,
the Friendly Fridge in the Bronx.
And I was getting feedback that,
whenever my bread was
there people were so happy.
They loved having it.
So I was getting all
this appreciation for it.
So I was like, "What else
can I do with my bread?"
And I belonged to a kayak club.
And we have a barbecue night
and I was bringing my bread.
And there were people
there who make honey,
and pickles and all kinds of things.
So I started swapping with them.
And then my favorite item
is this piece of artwork by Nina Velasquez
that she made of me
which has become like my,
I, you know, the,
you know, she ID'd me as the
bread baker of Riverdale.
I so appreciate it.
And then, other people were saying,
"I don't make anything,
but I want your bread.
Can I buy it?"
And suddenly I found myself
in the bread business.
- Yeah amen, I'm one of those people.
(audience claps)
I don't make bread, but I love to eat it.
I love this story, this is so awesome.
My like how life, you know,
it gets hard, but then
it takes a left turn
and it's like a whole nother
beautiful chapter, so.
- [Arnie] Yes.
- Yeah, congratulations, man.
I wanna try your bread.
Thank you, Arnie.
(audience applauds)
I'm liking your post right now.
- [Arnie] Thank you.
- And that's not all, my man,
our season-long partner,
Pilot pen makers of Frixion,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like you, sir.
So they're gonna give you
$1,000 just for being you.
(audience cheers)
- Oh, woody.
Oh my, thank you.
- You can make, you can make
a lot of bread with that.
That's all I'm saying.
Feel free to send some here.
- [Arnie] Yes.
- [Kelly] Okay, thank you so much, Arnie.